apprenant leurs secrets pour déplacer ces énormes pierres.
Il s'avère que les Cyclopes ne sont pas si forts que ça.
Ils sont juste très ingénieux avec leurs matériaux.
Les créatures pierreuses bancales que vous voyez derrière moi
sont le fruit de cette collaboration.
OK, les Cyclopes sont des créatures mythiques,
mais ces merveilles sont bien réelles.
Des gens les ont créées.
Mais ils ont aussi créé les mythes qui les entourent.
Et quand on parle de merveilles, il y a un épais tissu connectif
entre mythologie et réalité.
L'Île de Pâques, par exemple.
Quand les explorateurs hollandais découvrirent l'île,
ils demandèrent aux habitants de Rapa Nui
comment leurs ancêtres avaient pu déplacer ces gigantesques statues.
Les Rapa Nui ont répondu :
« Nos ancêtres n'ont pas déplacé les statues,
les statues marchèrent d'elles-mêmes. »
Pendant des siècles, cela fut rejeté, mais c'était vrai.
Les statues, appelées moais, furent transportées debout,
pivotant d'un côté à l'autre.
OK ?
Les moais sont spectaculaires pour les visiteurs d'aujourd'hui,
mais imaginez-vous là-bas à l'époque
entourés de moais colossaux marchant sur l'île.
Car la vraie valeur n'était pas dans les monuments eux-mêmes
mais dans le rituel permettant aux pierres de prendre vie.
En tant qu'architecte, je poursuis ce rêve.
Comment intégrer ce côté mythique à notre vision de la construction ?
Je me suis mis au défi
en organisant des représentations
sur le thème ancien, mais simple,
du déplacement et du redressement d'objets lourds,
comme ce mégalithe de cinq mètres conçu pour marcher
et se tenir debout ;
ou ce géant de deux tonnes qui prend vie
pour dancer sur scène.
En pensant à l'architecture
comme à un spectacle plutôt qu'un produit fini,
de la conception à l'aboutissement,
on redécouvre des méthodes ingénieuses.
Le débat sur notre avenir
se concentre sur la technologie, l'efficacité et la rapidité.
Mais les Cyclopes m'ont appris une chose :
les merveilles sont ingénieuses, spectaculaires
et durables...
grâce à leur masse et leur mystère.
Pendant que d'autres cherchent encore comment on a construit ces merveilles,
j'ai demandé aux Cyclopes comment créer le mystère
qui pousse à poser cette question.
A l'ère des constructions façonnées
pour durer 30, peut-être 60 ans,
j'aimerais apprendre comment créer quelque chose
qui puisse divertir pour l'éternité.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)